dick the console of the TARDIS so it's
December and I have one other kind of
list could I do for Doctor Who other
than to rank the Christmas specials I
did debate waiting until twice upon a
time comes out and then doing a ranking
of all those but I'd rather just do the
existing ones up to now which is twelve
Doctor Who Christmas specials that I am
now going to rank before I get into the
ranking I want to be honest about
something I enjoyed the Christmas
specials they're not my favorite thing
and I say that you know being well aware
that a lot of them fit into sort of the
British tradition of pantomime I didn't
grow up with pantomime it's not that
thing it's not my thing
so and I'm not you know belittling it as
a as a thing and I usually enjoy these
but the fact that they are you often
deliberately lighter goofy kind of
things it doesn't always work for me so
that's also part of the reason I wanted
to do this list is because most of these
episodes aren't gonna show up another
list that I do so I wouldn't get a
chance to talk about them otherwise but
with that sort of preface out of the way
let's get to it talking about my ranking
for the as of this recording twelve
Christmas specials of Doctor Who's
starting at the bottom will working our
way up and we will start with one that
is probably not the one everyone's
expecting to be at the bottom the
runaway bride so this one might come as
a surprise to people because when I did
my ten worst episodes written by Russell
T Davies this was on there but another
Christmas special was ranked lower than
that and I'm gonna kind of come to that
a little bit later but basically to put
it simply when it comes to what you
would get out of Christmas special
because I'm kind of I'm grating these a
bit on a curve doing a list that is only
these this episode just doesn't have a
lot to recommend it now I'm gonna
reiterate I love Donna Donna is my
favorite companion
and her introduction the way she's
played in this is actually kind of
important to how her overall art goes in
her journey as a character she's still
really annoying in this first episode
her first appearance the racnoss a it's
a great design it's an awesome look the
performance is really hammy and her
trying to speak through those fake teeth
it's really distracting to try and
listen to so you know there's all of
that the return of the Christmas robots
which I'll come back to them so between
all those things but ultimately the
reason I put this at the bottom is not
because all the things I just mentioned
are the worst thing ever
but I can't tell you what the redeeming
feature of this episode really is when
taken into a thing unto itself
all right if I look at the bigger scale
you know young introduction of Donna so
she can have an arc later all this stuff
cool awesome that works but when you
look at the thing in isolation
there isn't a lot of reason for me to
come back and watch this one so that's
going to occupy the bottom spot we're
gonna move up one to the one that I
think a lot of people expect it to be at
the bottom spot and that is the doctor
the widow and the Wardrobe which I think
it's kind of an underrated episode if
I'm being completely honest I see people
like ask why this wasn't in my top my
top 10 worst Doctor Who episodes of all
time and it's because I don't think it's
that bad I mean I I say that by the
standards of the Christmas specials you
take it I compare to you know the really
good episodes of a normal series episode
and yeah it's got a lot of issues but as
a Christmas special it's it's okay
there's nothing really exceptional about
it but it does have one element that I
genuinely really like and that's match I
think Madge is a fun character I like
her quite a bit I like her dynamic with
the doctor but she is pretty much the
only thing that I can point to as being
genuinely good as opposed to the other
other elements that I just kind of plan
out and go that's not as bad as
everybody says she is really kind of the
only at least of my my genuine redeeming
factor about the episode but I do
actually really like her as a character
and so for that reason I think this
episode gets more flak than it deserves
but it's still not great next up number
10 the Christmas invasion now this is an
episode that I basically don't enjoy
until about the last quarter third
basically once David Tennant wakes up
and you know he's on the the ship and
he's dealing with the sicker acts and
everything about him
Gould I love it I love his whole thing
with the blood control the big red
button that he's got a push in his
darker moments his serious moments the
fact that he just you know starts
talking and admits that he doesn't
really know who he is yet all that stuff
is wonderful but prior to that we have
the Santa robots and the killer tree and
Jackie being annoying and one decent
joke with Harriet Jones which is just a
call back to an earlier joke anyway and
then the rest of it's just kind of me
but it did that that last segment once
David Tennant wakes up it really is
wonderful as triumphant in its energetic
it's fun and he nailed his take on the
doctor immediately but it's kind of a
slog waiting for him to just take over
the story now this was the one when I
did my rankings for Russell T Davies
episodes that I put as being worse than
the runaway bride and I think I'm from a
writing perspective I do think it's kind
of worse as a Christmas episode though I
think it's better because as good as
much as I just rag Don the Santa's and
the Christmas sufferer or whatever like
the runaway bride doesn't even really
have a Christmas element to it which
just makes it stand out all the more in
addition to not really having that one
elevating factor so that's the reason
that they're in a different order here
than they were when I talked about both
these episodes before number 9 the
snowmen this is another one that I look
back on and I
want to like more because there's some
stuff that got seated that I really
liked later like later on I love Richard
II grant when he returns as the great
intelligence but his part here as just
the the the doctor that the intelligence
talks to is kind of Nick doesn't really
take advantage of him as an actor I'm
using Ian McKellen to voice the great
intelligence that was solid I dig that
this the fact that the snowmen got the
title and they're just kind of they're
like they feel utterly superfluous they
feel like they're just there to tie it
in to somehow justify it being a
Christmas episode I will have killer
snowmen yeah and they don't mean
anything they don't do much and I guess
talking about this version of Clara is
irritating for me because I like this
version of Clara better than the version
of Clara that actually came into the
TARDIS and it's something as simple as
just having her not be from modern time
and yet have you know this this quick
wit about her there's something about
the dynamic that she's got with the
doctor right off the bat that I really
enjoy and it kind of I both enjoy seeing
it irritates me because I go you were a
better version why couldn't you and then
she dies but you know there are good
there are good elements here as I said
Ian McKellen saw Matt Smith does decent
work a little unremarkable there are
some really nice moments with with Strax
and and some of the other returning
characters so there's definitely stuff
that is that's good and solid here but
it's just overall it's just kind of me
number eight the time of the doctor I
don't know if I'm ever gonna get around
well I probably will eventually I don't
know when I'll get around to ranking
regeneration stories this is one of my
least favorite regeneration stories
though and it's weird for me to say that
because there's a lot about this episode
that is stuff that I normally like it's
got kind of
almost a bedtime story feel to it which
is a vibe in general that I enjoy but I
think it's a very ill fit for a
regeneration story especially one that
we know going in is the regeneration
story I think as much as I as I have
kind of bagged on Russell T Davies at
various points one thing that he
understood when it came to his
regenerations it it is a good idea to
have a kind of a real rip-roaring
adventure so that you can get something
you can get wrapped up in then it helps
power you along to the what will
ultimately be the replacement of the
doctor when you do something slower
paced and more kind of contemplative
like this it it comes off a little
melancholy in a self indulgent way and
you're just kind of checking watch going
you're gonna regenerate anytime soon
what's gonna happen this kind of make
him do it cuz what's going on right now
is kind of just meandering and I think
that's the thing the doctor just just
kind of hangs out here for a while until
he dies hmm but again that said I've got
it right tighter than the other stuff
because when it works it works very well
I think the actual moment in the TARDIS
with Matt Smith's regeneration is very
well done well delivered it's emotional
if you really cared for Matt Smith's
doctor which I do that moment with him
seeing Amy that's a really nice moment
Clara works in this episode better than
she had to me for me pretty much up to
that point and there are and like I said
it is a vibe that I like in general this
was an episode I liked a little bit
better when I rewatched it as opposed to
seeing it the first time and sort of
sort of sinking into the the vibe of it
but I just think that that vibe is kind
of an ill fit for a regeneration story
if this had been more of a the doctor
stays in a town a long time protecting
it sort of
and it's like a Christmas tradition that
he has here sort of thing but it hadn't
been a regeneration story I'd probably
like this a lot and it's just the the
fact that it had to do both it's kind of
why a doesn't quite work for me even
though as I said it's got some good
parts number seven and this basically
brings us into the ones that I I like
for the most part and that is voyage of
the Damned
now I some people really love the heck
out of this episode I'm not quite there
but it is fun and it has kind of that
romp feel that I think they are they're
kind of allowed to get away with a
little bit more in the Christmas episode
than other episodes that said it is it
is kind of goofy the you know the
passengers are a little bit none of them
are particularly well most of them
aren't particularly engaging although I
find it interesting you know which ones
die which ones live that whole dynamic I
think works pretty well I kind of like
the feel for Tennant and his performance
in this one that he's like just looking
to kind of relax and chill for a little
bit but well the universe has other
plans we have the introduction of Wilf
I love Wilf I think Astrid is a really
good one off companion and Kylie Minogue
plays her pretty well the villains goofy
as heck again I know pantomime but I
still don't like it it's cartoonish and
doesn't really work for me
but overall it's fun in his pretty
lights maybe a little overly long for
the fact that he is kind of like fair
but it's enjoyable number six the next
Doctor this one has a push-pull of
elements that I don't really like and
elements that I love and this is a and
that's kind of come up before with some
of these ones I'm talking about but this
is a case where the elements that I
don't love I aren't dragging down the
other stuff that much so for some that I
don't love the use of the Cybermen in
this they're fairly disposable the cyber
shades is a slightly interesting idea
that it does nothing with the cyber King
is goofy the villainous of the piece has
some interesting ideas behind the eye
the concept of her but it also feels
like there isn't really much going on
but i love david morrissey in this
episode i think he is this wonderful
sort of victorian take on the doctor and
you kind of do feel like oh i would have
been happy to keep watching him by the
end of it but he if he's good when he
thinks he's the doctor he's great when
he's jackson lake and i love the you
know him cheering for the doctor i adore
him going in the TARDIS seeing that it's
bigger on the inside and then we're just
running away going that's enough that's
enough but like with this smile on his
face and he really has this wonderful
joy about his performance and yet also
manages to capture the pain of having
lost his wife and the dread when he sees
his child in danger his performance
really does make this episode for me and
thankfully because he's pretty much
across the entire thing it buoys the
entire episode even though it's got some
other wonky elements number five a
christmas carol in my estimation this is
probably the most christmas
appropriately Christmassy of the
episodes it's the one that really leans
into we are doing Christmas with this
and i think it was a very smart idea to
just call it a Christmas carol so that
the intentions were clear right up front
if they called it something else you
know some sort of cute name where it's
not clear where they're going and then
they just started doing their version of
christmas carol i would have been
annoyed but sort of knowing going in
from the title alone that's what i'm
getting i have a lot of fun with this I
think Michael Gambon is a wonderful
actor he does a really good job
portraying this character that he plays
I really enjoy you know Matt Smith
trying to do adjust this stuff and sort
of Han doing it with this joy but then
seeing things start to come apart and be
like oh god can he actually pull this
off and just there and again there are
goofy elements the flying fish what but
at this point you know you kind of have
to just swallow a couple of really goofy
elements when it comes to the Christmas
episodes and I think it's just a good
Doctor Who version of the classic
Christmas story of Scrooge
I think it makes its intentions clear
upfront it does it very well there's
some really heartfelt moments in it I
enjoy it number four
last Christmas if it wasn't for one
specific thing about this this might
even be my number one but I'll come back
to that so this one should be tonal
whiplash because we literally have Santa
Claus yet at the same time have
something that looks like the face
hugger from alien doing this dream
within a dream waking nightmare thing
these two things should not go together
and I wouldn't be shocked to find out in
the comments at the end of all this that
for some people they don't go together
but for me somehow yeah it works I mean
a big part of it is Nick Frost is
wonderful as Santa he's got a terrific
chemistry bouncing off of Capaldi and
then for some reason like how dark and
cerebral the story gets really works for
me it's hard for me to nail down exactly
why that is now the one thing that I'll
say that drags this thing down is that
this marks the second of what would
ultimately end up being three perfectly
good exit points for Clara to leave the
show but then she doesn't there was one
in death in heaven they'd be one later
and face the Raven and there's this one
here and each time finding out she was
coming back after that perfectly good
exit always frustrated me and in this
one they actually have her comeback in
the episode itself and it's annoying
because she was good in the episode and
it would have been a perfectly good
satisfying leap off point for her and
they didn't do it so that ends up being
a somewhat hefty black mark on an
episode that I otherwise really liked
number three the husbands of River Song
so this one it's interesting that
oftentimes with these ones that end up
higher they've got many of the same
elements at play as the ones that I rank
lower they just manage to do them better
so like for example much like voyage of
the Damned this features a flat-out
goofy villain but the fact that other
characters acknowledge that he's kind of
goofy and that he's a bit more sporadic
and we get him in very limited doses I
think makes him go down better than max
Capricorn did for me
I really like seeing the doctor you know
around River and for the first time he
knows stuff that she doesn't and I like
that that actually throws him off and
he's kind of like well wait what do you
mean you know recognize me
and I think Capaldi had really good
chemistry without its king that he has a
really good chemistry with almost
everybody that he ever has significant
scenes with now that I think about it
that might have been his secret
superpower as a as the doctor just
really played well off other characters
but I'm really glad that Capelli got to
have this episode with Alex Kingston it
manages to be you know exciting and
thrilling and it has the wonderful
moment from reverie which is like I'm an
archaeologist from the future I dug you
up like oh that's a sweet moment and
then the the note that it ends on and
sort of the nice sort of bittersweet
goodbye of that it's like okay this is
us saying goodbye but we're gonna make
it last and we're gonna make it count
and it's kind of sweet and it's kind of
beautiful and it's one that I like I've
come to enjoy more as time has gone on
so yeah I I do enjoy this one we've got
two left to go so taking up the number
two spots the return of doctor Mysterio
now I talked about this one before when
I did my top 10 funniest Doctor Who
episodes because it occupied the number
one spot there and I will be flat-out a
big part of why this works so well for
me is I not only loved Doctor Who I
loved superheroes
I loved Superman so to see them do this
wonderful not spoof not
parody of Superman it's not making fun
of it but it's having fun with the
tropes but also being respectful of this
genre that normally wouldn't enter into
Doctor Who it balances all that really
well again
terrific chemistry terrific rapport with
the doctor and with everybody else we
get nardole back working better than he
did in husbands of River Song happily
really in a lot of ways I think they
only if the aspect of this is the
villains are kind of disposable but the
villains also aren't the point the point
is the the doctor and this hero and I
really love the way that it plays with
the genre I love the way that the
characters react to each other into the
situations it's got snappy banter
dialogue which I always love I just have
so much fun with this episode doesn't go
and make my number one spot though cuz
mine my choice for the number one Doctor
Who Christmas special as of until the
next one comes out cuz who knows where
that would fall on this list but it's
going to be the end of time part one
this is kind of interesting for me
because normally I don't deal with only
one half of the two-part story on its
own because if you watch my other list I
generally treat two parters as a single
story and talk about them in that
capacity but the second half of this
aired on New Year's so the only the
first half is a Christmas special so
looking at it by itself it's really
strong we get some wonderful bottle
again Wilf I mentioned already that I
love wealth but we get some really
strong moments of interaction between
him of the doctor that give us that
melancholy tone of the doctor knowing
that his end is coming and you get the
master and I again I've said this before
I like the unhinged sort of coming apart
barely together master better than the
version that we got back in series 3 I
like this more desperate version of the
master and I think Johnson plays him
better I think that he feels less
predictable he feels more dangerous and
the cliffhanger on this is awesome
because it's a double-layer cliffhanger
first you have the doctor has copied
himself across the entire planet which
is a little ridiculous but it's like oh
okay
Wow and then oh that voice that voice
Lee you've actually been hearing
narrating the whole episode up to this
point
with Timothy Dalton in as Rassilon the
Timelords
holy crap like what an amazing
cliffhanger and a good build to that
especially since it's really weird the
time wow it's coming back it felt right
and it felt earned even though there was
no hint that that was gonna be happening
at any point prior to that to that point
in the episode that point in the story
it's really good it's really fun it is
funny in the right ways you've got will
with his little crazy little hat and so
you get your little Christmas elements
you get all this stuff and a masterful
cliffhanger on top of it you've got John
Simm working better as the master you've
got Tennant bringing both the the fun
and the pathos because you can see he's
starting to really dread his own end
taking this on its own and not having to
incorporate it as the other half apart
do it justly as the as a one-off as a
Christmas special yeah that's my
favorite one so that's my ranking for
the Doctor Who Christmas specials what
do you think you think I'm crazy you
have your own ranking you want to share
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a
girl podcast that is a presentation of
firewater podcast network Fire and Water
podcast comm there's links for all this
stuff down below go down there to find
out more and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]